keep the tab open we're gonna be here
for a while this is exactly what we need
no this is exactly where we belong I've
got the next round I'll see I have been
friends for 15 years and we've been in
and out of rehab for 16 today's a day we
say no more to rehab
we quit Oh
tastes like home I think Dorothy and I
we've been through it all I mean she's
the only one that understood my
situation in rehab people look at us and
they say you should go to rehab and
that's when I say [ __ ] you it's it's
funny cause it's empty
Shirl I gained a few pounds sue me
there's no place like home bring in the
beets
Alice there's no place like home there's
no list I call auntie em and Uncle Henry
don't like the way I've turned out [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them in the ass with the
witch's broom
I [ __ ] can't [ __ ] turn in the
[ __ ] bar like tickety I love total
and I miss him so much
a sick [ __ ] rat he's a huge rat the
genocide and do anything for you just
walked around on a final I mean the only
thing about Dorothy is like she's always
like totally stood of that and I'm like
who gives a [ __ ]
I miss toto I killed him by accident so
Dorothy listen to this I was in the
middle of Walmart in the middle of the
card section and I was already freaking
out with all the heart-shaped [ __ ] just
cluster [ __ ] around me disgusting and
then this little towheaded toddler comes
up to me and he pokes me and he says off
with her head
growth and then I drop all the cough
syrup in the middle of the aisle I'm
sent to jail and all of the inmates are
calling me breaking bad not even if your
dick was a tornado what I know Alice but
you know what kids these days think that
the Wicked Witch knows how to play
Quidditch when really she doesn't
curiouser and curiouser
take this guy he probably thinks that
I'm just some daddy's girl with pigtails
when really I bet he's never met a woman
who's seen a black and white rainbow
I tell you any man that wants to go down
this maze needs to realize that I'm
gonna drive him so crazy that he'll be
talking to door knobs and a man who
doesn't have a heart big deal I've done
them I can't even look at a dick without
thinking of a caterpillar let alone
mushrooms oh yeah well you try having
monkeys give you an Indian burning you
become a choke of a town well you try
having a threesome with two fat twins
smudge consist all over my shoes that's
why I can't take em off will you try
eating a sugar cookie with a gluten
problem and you go up down up down in
size and it's like okay hello puberty
what you guys just stop inviting me hey
Anne Frank sorry but you have bad cell
phone reception where you're at and the
last time you were here you lost your
diary in the bathroom and you started
freaking out and we didn't want that to
happen to you again boo guys I've been
backing up my diary to the iCloud and as
you can see him a little more shell a
little more fun kind of relaxed um oh
this guy sent me a dick pic on tinder
and he was like hella circumsized
you